welcome to this engaging crash course on
creating your own platformer game with
Godot 4.0 Omar Zaki created this course
this beginner-friendly course is perfect
for those who are new to game
development and want to learn the ins
and outs of the Godot game engine
throughout the course you'll learn
everything from setting up your first 2D
scene and animating the player to
designing enemies incorporating UI
elements and implementing game saving
features by the end of this adventure
you'll have a solid foundation in Godot
4.0 and the skills to create your very
own captivating platformer game
welcome everyone to this course
in this course you will be learning a
variety of different topics including
animating a player Parallax background
we're going to be going through saving
and loading we're going to also be able
to create a very simple but nice AI mob
that's going to have to have nice
control on it and then lastly we're
going to have Collectibles and as a
bonus which actually it's a bonus in the
beginning we'll be going through tile
maps and how to set up a tile that inner
animated player we'll be going to a few
different topics so we'll have animated
Sprite we'll have an animation player
and we'll be going through physics
simple physics in The Parallax
background we will be doing Parallax
mirroring and we'll be discussing how to
active properly do that in the saving
and loading we are going to be using a
very nice Godot built-in function which
is going to allow us to access files and
then through that we're going to be also
creating Json files with it through
dictionary so we're going to be
discussing dictionaries as well as how
to invert that into a Json file and for
the simple mob AI we're going to be
going through area 2D this is a very
powerful tool in Widow that I would very
much suggest you learn very quickly it's
very very useful for a variety of
different things as you will see as we
kind of go along in the course and
lastly Collectibles we're going to be
going to timers which is just a simple
timer the last we have tween tween is a
very simple way to animate things in
Godot and I'll be going through a few
ways to do that and it'll be very fun so
stay tuned for that and it'll be really
exciting
okay so the first thing we're going to
want to do is obviously download the
actual engine right and so Godot is
actually very unique compared to other
engines where the download process is
actually very very simple and very quick
so all we're going to have to do is is
download Godot we're gonna have to go to
download latest we're going to go we are
going to use group 4 if you're watching
this video and you uh go to four point
something is out you can download that
it shouldn't be too different it should
be pretty much the same now go to 3.5
and and previous versions might be
slightly different in the code so I
wouldn't suggest downloading them I
would suggest downloading 4.0 and
further so let's download 4.0 we just
click that download this you will get a
zip file so let's minimize this and see
what we get let me close that
this is the zip file you should get if
we open this up we will see two things
we will see the let's actually just drag
these out and see what we have
so I'm not going to replace this I'm
actually going to skip that because I
already have it so we have go4 this is
for the windows version
and then we also have the console now we
don't need the console so we're going to
delete that and now we have the windows
4 stable we're just going to launch that
and there you go that's good for
download it so as you can see it's very
quick it took a minute and that's a lot
easier than Unity or Unreal Engine so
the next thing we're going to want to do
is actually create a project so now as
you can see these are my projects so if
once you've created a project it will
always show up here we have the about we
don't have to worry about that we have
asset Library projects we're not going
to worry about this either but it might
be useful for you later on maybe once
you finish watching this video
essentially this is a public repository
for people who actually use the engine
and make their own projects and want to
share it with fellow developers so if
you want to actually download your own
demo or upload your own demo that would
be here so there is also a website you
can do that which should be really cool
but this is also built into the good
engine so aside from that we're going to
be going to local projects this is going
to be on your actual
computers so I'm going to go ahead new
project we're going to choose where we
want this first and I'm going to put
this in
my desktop so you can choose wherever
you want to put it and let's name this
new
platformer game
and here we're gonna have to create a
folder so we have the option create
folder it has created a folder on the
side as you can see right above my head
and now we have a few different options
we have forward mobile compatibility now
what are these so forward is essentially
for 3D Graphics you can read it it's
basically just for 3D if you're doing a
3D game you do forward plus if you're
doing a 2d game you would do mobile now
it's not only for mobile because it does
support desktop but it is basically just
for 2D now compatibility I believe is
still
um in kind of beta testing and it has a
few bugs and it's but it's basically for
2D as well so
I would suggest we're just going to be
using mobile at the time of this video
If none of these are available if they
change a little bit just look for the
one that's more suited for 2D but
obviously this is just the renderer so
we're not going to worry too much about
it and for the Version Control you can
just go click none and that's it so now
let's create an edit and it's going to
create our project
there we go and we're left with a
complete blank slate and as you can see
our screen is completely blank let me
explain let's go through a few things so
on the top we have 2D and 3D so as you
can see when I click the three it shows
us kind of a 3D plane and we have four
or three planes right so we have the
blue red and green and that just
signifies that we're in a 3D plane and
if we go to 2D well everything kind of
becomes 2D so we also have script we
don't have any scripts yet so they're
completely empty we have asset Library
that's essentially library that you guys
saw before this is things that is it's
basically a public repository it's very
useful but uh at the in the moment we're
not going to use it okay
next up is the actual scene so let's get
started with our actual scene so in
order to actually run something we need
a scene what is it what is a scene you
might ask well a scene is essentially
something that we save in our project so
on the left here we can see that there's
a bunch of nodes and things so what
we're going to do is we're just going to
click 2D scene we're gonna rename this
by double clicking we're gonna type main
we're going to click uh control s and
we're going to save it into our main
folder so this is our main folder which
is res dot uh Slash whatever and there
we go we now have our main scene now we
can go to the top right you see a run
project or F5 we can click that and
we're going to select current and this
will just run our project into Main and
so now we've run our first project in
Godot
awesome next up is going to actually be
adding things to that scene so what do
we want to do well first of all we have
to plan what we actually want to do
right so the first thing we're going to
do is we're going to actually create a
menu screen so to do that we're going to
add buttons and when we go into
um the top left we have it plus five
what is this this is an ad child node so
Godot Works in nodes if you don't know
what nodes are they are basically just
objects essentially that we can add to
our scene and edit things really easily
so on the top here is a 2d node a 2d
node is something that just holds a
position and is allowed it allows us to
have a 2d thing on our screen so next up
we're going to just add to this node
what we're going to add is we're going
to add buttons so that will be under the
control section if we go to a canvas
item you'll see that we have two things
we have control node and control
so these are this is going to have main
most the stuff that we're going to be
using so we have a bunch of cool things
that you can look through we have
animated Sprite audio listener back
buffer bone we don't have to worry about
these ones CPU particle that's for
particles those are very complicated so
we're not going to worry about them too
much we have camera 2D and a bunch of
other really cool things so
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to find our button that we
want to add and if you can't find it
like I can't find it right now we're
just going to search it up so we search
a button and we have a few different
options so the first thing is to look
through them so we have button check
button color paper picker button menu
button option button link button and
texture button and of course my kind of
favorite touch screen button so this is
really good for mobile so we're not
going to touch this and next up is our
button
this is one of my defaults and now we
also have texture button texture button
is usually used essentially for
something let's say you've created a
texture of a button outside of Godot
like you have a UI expert who has
created a button for you and you want to
use that in your good old project this
is the node that you would use but for
us in this project we are going to be
using a standard theme button or a
button so let's create this let's add it
and if we zoom in a little bit we can
see our button and kind of just make it
a little bigger
and zoom back out and we can kind of
drag it to the middle and now what we
can do is add text to it on the right so
on the right we can see that there is
text and we can just add to it and we
can now see that we can add text and we
can add play so let's add two buttons so
to duplicate it what we can just do is
Ctrl D or you can just right click
and control uh duplicate so this one
will be the play button so let's see
rename that to play this will be our
quit button so we're going to rename
this to quit and right here we're just
going to drag this down we're going to
type the text as quit on the right so
you can see the text has changed to quit
and if I zoom in I should be able to see
both of them now so the first thing
we're going to do is add a script to the
main so to add a script as on the top
left above me you should be able to see
it attach a new script
and what we're going to do is we're
going to look at these so we have
templates and essentially what we want
to do is just add the template node
default this is going to basically add a
completely new script that has nothing
on it the language at the moment we only
have GD script if you want more
languages I'm pretty sure you have to
export that or import that into Godot
but we're not going to do that we're
just going to be using GD script and the
path that we wanted you can change that
here if you have more folders or we
don't have any folders yet so we're just
going to save it in main let's create it
and now we're going to save and now what
we're going to do is we're just going to
delete these we don't need any of those
functions so now all we need is extends
node 2D so let's go to our quit button
and what we'll do is we'll go to the
a scene and click our quit button and on
the left or on the right sorry we have
inspector node and history so inspector
essentially allows us to change all the
settings of the actual button and how it
looks I'll do those things so we have
layout we have transform we're all able
to change the transform of it the size
position scale rotation we can rotate it
around I I would definitely recommend if
you don't understand any of this
definitely play around with it it's
really cool to kind of just play around
with things and see how it works we have
tooltip this is actually kind of cool if
you hover it'll it'll perfectly explain
it it's essentially when I hover it
it'll give me something so let's type in
this
uh quit button
now if I play this
and I hover it it'll give me a tool tip
it'll say what this is this is the quick
button so we don't want that in our game
so we're just going to remove that but
it is very useful for other various
things right the focus a bunch of other
things that you might not understand but
that's okay so for now just kind of play
around with things that you might
understand
um and let's move on so the next thing
we're going to do is go to node and now
in here we have signals and groups so
groups we're not going to use however
there are good videos on it I would
definitely recommend learning it it is a
very powerful tool in Godot so aside
from that we're gonna we have signals
that's what we're going to be focusing
on and using so signals are essentially
when I click the button I want something
to happen if I want something to happen
I have to send a signal so I have to
send the signal from this button to the
script so how do I do that well I do
that here so how do I actually do that
though in here so what I can do is I I
basically look through all these signals
and look for something so this will tell
me if this will send a signal when the
button is pressed this will send a
signal when the button is closed down
this will send me a signal when the
button goes up Etc so there's a bunch of
things that in here that are very useful
so the first thing we're going to do or
we want is rest so we want to check if
the button is pressed to do that all we
do is double click it we double click
pressed this will pop up and now we can
just connect it to our main script so we
just we don't have to change anything we
just press connect and now in here we
now have a function that goes from quit
to script so in here what we'll do is
we'll actually program the quit function
so to do that we're just going to say
get tree
dot quit
and now all we have to do is play
test it
awesome we now have a quit button that
works so every time I play and I quit
click the quit button it will now quit
our game so that is how we create a
super simple quit button all we have to
do is get tree this will essentially get
the entire tree and then quit so X
explain that a little bit better so when
we play our game we have on the left we
have remote or local and remote so local
are the things that I'm locally changing
I'm changing in here right when I play
the game remote is like
actual thing that is happening in the
game right so here's our main function
that we have and if I have something
else it'll also be in here so root is
the root of the entire game that I have
now Above This that it what it doesn't
show is tree it's not really above it
but it's more so everything so that this
entire thing is tree so what we're doing
in our script is we're getting the tree
and this entire thing and then we're
gonna quit right
so that's how we essentially quit the
the game awesome next up is Play We want
to actually have a play button so to do
that we're gonna have to create another
scene so here on the left right next to
my head you should be able to see main.c
now we want another scene that will be
our world so this is going to be our
world so we're going to save it as World
we're going to save it we're gonna save
in here and now next to my head you
should be able to see world so we're
gonna basically take our play we're
gonna connect it to our main and we're
gonna go to world now I want you to try
connecting the signal into your main
function
so pause the video try that and uh if it
doesn't work unpause the video and I
will now do it so let's do it so let's
go to pressed let's go to the node
signal pressed and let's connect it to
our main so in here we now have our play
press button or function or a signal
sorry
now what do we want to do we want to
change the scene so how do we do that
well there's a function where we can
just say get tree
let's say get three and then we will say
change scene
to file or to pact now there's two
different options which one we're going
to do we're going to do two file to
practice something different that we
don't usually use so we're going to do
two file and we're going to go to the
world scene so
essentially what we're doing is we're
getting the tree and we're just going to
change our scene which is the main into
the file world right so we can see our
world here and another way to change
this is this is a quick tip if you
wanted to change this maybe you chose
the wrong thing what you can do is
highlight it or just delete it and we
can select the actual thing that we want
like worlds and we just drag it in or a
third option is copy path and copy paste
it as you can see that's the path of the
world's file so now what we can do is we
can let's actually be able to
differentiate this by going to our world
and what we'll do is We'll add a node
we'll just adding the label
so what a label is is it's just text
it's basically just a label that
actually has adds text to our screen so
we'll say this is the world and then
we'll save this we'll play
and now what we can do is press play and
now we change to this is the world so
we've changed our scene to the world
scene awesome all right so the next
thing we're going to want to do is
download this asset pack um this is
going to be the art that we use for our
game
so the first thing we're going to do is
Click download you don't have to pay you
can just say no thanks take me to the
downloads and we're going to download
all four of these once you click
download it'll prompt you to take
download it to a location you download
it to wherever you want and then we can
close that tab
and as you can see here I've exported
all the files that we need you can do
that very fast by just selecting all
those files right clicking and compress
or sorry extract each archive two
separate folder and then from there what
you're going to do is select all four of
these files open up the project that we
have and we're just going to take all of
them and drag them in so once you've
dragged them in as you can see I've
already done that here they're my four
files and once you've done that that's
it now all we need to do is make sure
that the pixelation is proper so
in order to do that here we can see the
pixelation is proper for the good dough
icon however for you might not be look
like that so to fix that in our project
settings what we're going to do is we're
going to go to filter settings and then
we're going to search up texture and
then we'll be prompted to rendering
textures when a unselect the filter
setting but now we have textures
selected here in the default textures
filter you can see mine is nearest
however the default is linear so we're
going to want to change that to nearest
or you're going to want to do that all
right and now let's close that and now
we can see that it's pixelated for you
at least and if you're not if it's not
we can actually look at the texture in
each node each node will have its filter
set to inherit inherit means we're just
going to take the project settings which
we just set however I can change it to
linear or nearest or whatever you want
however I'm just going to keep it as
inherent or I'm just going to delete
this node because we don't need it next
up we're going to delete the label
because we no longer need that
instead what we're going to do is we're
going to get started on our player and
background so the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to create our
player first so in order to do that we
have to make a character body 2D so
we're going to have this as a separate
scene the reason is because it's going
to inherit this scene and I'll explain
that just in a second so first let's
create a new folder for this guy and
call it player and then let's save it as
player so rename the node to player dot
scene
so if you're wondering what he's tscn
stands for it just means that it's a
scene next up we're going to add
actually let's not add the script just
yet let's look at this error what does
this error say
consider adding a collision shape 2D or
Collision polygon 2D as a child to
Define its shape this node has no shape
as it can't Collide or interact with
other players or things so that is true
we now have to add a collision shape
here you can read this error as well
it's basically just saying we haven't
given it a shape so now we have a
character body 2D and its shape so here
we can actually Define the shape we'll
give it a capsule we can zoom in and
look at the capsule so let's now add our
Sprite so let's take a look at our files
and look for our player should be in
here
the look under PNG I'm going to go to
Sprites you can find player and there we
go now we have our player and here we
can see that we have a bunch of uh
Sprites so here now what we can do is
take is Find animated Sprite 2D
will basically add a animated Sprite and
we're going to Sprite go to Sprite
frames and make a new Sprite
all right so from here what animation 2D
or animated Sprite allows us to do is
basically organize all this there's a
different way to do this however we're
going to be getting into that in a bit
so
the first thing I'm going to do is add
all the animations we need we're not
going to use all of them we're just
going to use idle
run
and
no for now those are the three that
we're going to use so for idle all we
should be able to do I believe is just
drag this in and drag and drop it so
select all of them and drag and drop and
jump
what we can do is just take all these
and drag it in so now we have up and
down and next we'll go to run
drag all these and pop them in the next
thing we want to make sure that we're
looking at or one tip real quick is if
your Sprites or Sprite sheet like this
what we can do so we have a Sprite run
what we can do instead here let's make a
new run animation or we'll do Crouch
so let's look at let's
say this is Crouch so if you have a
spreadsheet instead of separate files
what you can do is go over here to this
ad frame from spreadsheet select it and
find the nope that's the house we want
to find the file that we're looking for
so double click PNG Sprite sheets and
now what we can do is let's actually do
the hard though because we might
actually use this later on so let's look
zoom in by control zooming and now we
can do is actually adjust this on the
top left we have horizontal and vertical
so for our
vertical we only have one right for the
horizontal we have two so now we can
select both the frames and add those two
frames and now we can see here there's
our hurt so let's actually change this
name to
um part all right we'll actually change
this to death so that'll be our death
animation
okay next up we're going to actually
take a look at animating these so to do
this very quickly and simply
we want to First actually make sure our
player can do stuff and move right so
let's go to our player rename it player
go to script we're going to add a script
we're going to use the template that
Godot actually gives us this is a new
addition to go to four so it's very
useful so let's just create it we're not
going to do built-in if you do built-in
the file will not save here it will just
be built into the actual node which we
don't want we want the path to be able
to edit it later on and look it up so
let's not have built in we're going to
use the template and all this create and
now what we should have is a nice
default template for our code and now
what we can do is go to our world we can
add our player by actually finding our
player so let's find our player drag him
in and there we go we now have our
player now what we want to do is
actually add floor so to do that we're
going to add a static body a static body
is a physics physic body for 2D physics
which is static or moves only by script
so this is useful generally for two
things either you know a floor or useful
for walls and Floors or a platform that
you might want to move yourself using
Code so those are pretty useful things
to use for this static body and again we
have to add a collision shape for it
and for this one it's actually very easy
to create what we can do is just drag
the Collision shape out and that is our
Collision for the for the player so we
can now just save this as our floor what
we can do though for the wall is we can
just duplicate this by saying Ctrl D we
can control the the Collision shape and
what now what we have to do is make sure
we actually make it unique why because
what happens is if I control d
if I duplicate it if I edit this one it
actually edits the original one as well
so in order to change this or fix this
we're going to go to the shape on the
top right and make it unique so now when
I edit this it won't edit the first one
so now what we can do is duplicate this
one and drag it over here and that's our
wall all right let's now also add a
panel
a panel is basically just a block of
sprite essentially it's just a block
panel that we can actually draw with
this isn't a good way to actually make a
floor we're going to add a legitimate
floor later on but for now this will act
as our visible floor so now when I play
we can go play and here's our character
he's showing the hurt animation but
that's okay but now we can walk and run
or walk stop idle and jump awesome and
we didn't do anything we didn't even
look at the code but now what we can do
is go back to the player code and take a
look at it so let's go through this and
understand a little bit so first we're
setting a few variables we have speed
jump velocity and gravity gravity is
essentially just the gravity default
that the project is using the jump speed
is negative 400 motor jump velocity
sorry and speed is 300. now let's take a
look at the actual code as to what is
how what is happening so physics process
is a function that is essentially called
every physics
end so it's called I believe it's like
six or six hundred or six thousand times
a second something like that it's it's a
lot so it's being called quite a bit
and next so n is passing through Delta
so if not is on floor we're going to do
this so what does this mean if not on is
on floor meaning if we're in the air so
if we're in the air we're going to
actually add velocity right so we're
going to add velocity to the Y direction
we're going to add it as gravity times
Delta so essentially we're just making
the player get get pulled down if we're
jumping or if we're in the air right if
we're not on the floor we're going to
pull them down to the ground next up is
we're going to see if we're jumping or
if we were asking the player to jump so
this is going to check the input so
input is action just pressed UI accept
this is the default
input that will actually edit later on
but that's okay for now we'll leave it
up that and is on floor so we can only
jump if we're on the floor
and then we jump right so this is how we
jump by making the velocity equal to
negative 400 and this will just
essentially make it negative 400 and
then we're going to get pulled back down
right
okay next up is the direction so what is
Direction This is essentially going to
look for our Direction in the X in the
axis so get access input dot get access
is just going to check which two keys
are being pressed if UI right oh sorry
if you write is being pressed we're
going to have direction is equal to one
if UI left is being pressed it's going
to be equal to negative one if it's
neither it's going to be equal to zero
so if Direction meaning we have
something then velocity.x is going to be
equal to Direction times speed so this
is going to be actually moving us
otherwise we're going to be moving our
velocity.x so our current velocity to
zero times speed or using the speed
um acceleration assumption this is
basically going from whatever number
we're at so let's say like 400 to 0 in
the speed amount of time
and then next up is our function move
and slide this is a built-in function
that Godot has that allows us to move
and actually slide along our floor so
now let's animate so let's actually take
a look at how we can do that the way we
can do that is by let's see let's add a
ready function so to do that we can say
funk ready and then let Godot complete
our sentence for us and then we can say
get node
animated Sprite dot lay
idle and we're going to play our idle
animation so make sure that it's called
it is spelled correctly because it is
also case Capital so if this was not
case Capital it would not work it'll
give you an error and it'll tell you to
fix it so play and see what happens so
that is my idle animation there we go
however when I move it doesn't do
anything so let's fix that so now what
we want to do there's a few things we're
going to actually do real quick instead
of get note here what we're going to do
is we're going to set our node outside a
function so we can access this node
everywhere however that's not going to
work because let's fix this error first
so that's not going to work because when
I try to access a node outside of a
function this isn't really going to work
because we want to essentially access it
on runtime so what we have to do is say
on ready variable animation and that'll
fix it so now we can access that
animation node right which is this node
in a ready function or anywhere else so
now what we can do is say let's say in
the direction we can say NM dot play
uh was it run I believe it was run
let's double check what we wrote in our
Animation Sprite frames yeah run so
we're going to play the Run animation if
we are running so otherwise what we'll
actually do is look here and we'll say
I know
so if we're actually moving we'll play
run if we're not moving then we'll play
idle so now let's look at what we have
so let's play so we're not moving so
we're playing idle now let's start
walking and as you can see our player is
starting to run however there's a few
different issues now the first issue is
going to be the actual animation and you
might think okay now what I can do is
say okay well I can just say Adam play
and jump
right and now when I jump it'll actually
animate my jump right so when I play
we play it'll play the jump however it's
not why because what's happening is it's
going the physics process does not care
what this animation is currently doing
when I call this function play it
doesn't matter if it's playing something
else it's not going to finish that
animation it's just going to play it
right away right so what's happening is
we're playing this animation right we've
we've checked that we clicked uh jump
we're gonna play it however what's
happening is we're going to keep going
down the code we're going to see that
the direction is either true or not if
it's not that means we're going to play
idle if it is we'll play run now one of
these two is essentially going to
override this so there's actually a
better way to essentially animate things
in Godot so what we're going to do is
we're going to delete all this
and we're going to delete this too we're
going to keep this on ready function and
we're going to go back to our 2D Sprite
and we're going to do two things first
so the first thing is we're going to
actually add a camera 2D because our
game is actually really really big so
there's a few different things we can
actually change the window so the window
is really big at the moment it's kind of
the default there's a few different
things we can do we can go to the
project settings we can go to window
display and we can change the viewport
width and height however this isn't
going to actually change the the
legitimate screen because this is just
going to change here let's actually test
in see what happens so if I divide both
by two
it's going to essentially divide the
actual screen so here we can see the if
we go back to world we can see the blue
marker that is our actual screen so it's
moved right it's gone smaller however
when I play it now looks like this so
our window is a lot smaller so we're not
going to be doing that we're going to
reset these what we're going to do
instead
we're going to go to our player we're
going to take our camera we're going to
enable it and we're going to zoom in so
we're going to zoom in maybe at like one
point
six
and if you want to separate these two
you can actually click the keychain guy
and that'll unlock these two so they're
no longer linked
I want them both to be linked so we're
going to just link it like that all
right next up make sure that it's
enabled and let's play and see what we
have so let's play and now our player is
looking a lot smaller or it's actually
zoomed in and we can see our player uh
Clearly Now Okay so the next thing we're
going to do is we're going to actually
use animation tree and animation
player so in Godot we have a few
different things to animate things
whether it's animated sprite animation
play right animation tree now animation
player is a very good tool that most
people use
more powerful tool that I
have two both of them
we're going to be using animation player
first and then we'll kind of transition
to animation tree and see how that works
so the first thing we're going to want
to do is go to animation create an
ad for each one so we'll go idle run
jump we'll add the death one as well
so from here what we can do is we can
actually there's a few different things
we can options we have so the first
option is we can find our player and as
you can see when we try
so let's say we win the idol so let's
try going idle and if I try dragging
this in nothing's going to happen right
I can't drag this into our animation
player like I did in the Animation
Sprite however because what the the way
the animation player works is
essentially the animation player allows
us to take a
key or a property of something and
change it over time so what this means
is if am I if I'm in my animation I can
change the camera zoom so if I go to
zoom I can animate the zoom I can key
this and then change it to another
position over one second right so what
we generally would do is take these
Sprite and animate it that way right so
a good way to generally do this is have
a big spreadsheet and just do it in that
one item that once sheet however we
don't have that we do have a few sheets
but that's still too many so what we'll
do instead is we'll use the animated
Sprite to actually do this so the way we
do this is actually a bit tricky and
Godot what we have to do is select the
animated Sprite we have to go to
animation
and now we will see the key now if you
don't do this what would happen is if
you have try to select the animated
Sprite and go here
it might be a bit tricky to actually
select the animation so you have to
select the animate the animation itself
from using the tab on the bottom not the
animation player a lot of people will
generally take the player and then
select the animation player to edit it
right so when I select the animation
player on the Node I can now see the
keys I can edit however if I try to do
that with the animated Sprite it won't
work because it's going to change the
node that is selected to animation
player so what we need to do is make
sure the Sprite frames is open down here
and then move to the animation player
the animation right so now what we can
do is go to animation select idle
go back to animation and then key that
so we're going to key this we don't have
to create reset track so now we've
changed the animation to idle now all we
can do is we can zoom in a little bit we
can take our frame
here
zoom in a little bit we'll go to yeah
we'll leave it at point one we'll go up
a frame and we're basically going to
manually
animate this by going up a frame
and that's it so we've we've put all the
frames in there okay so now what we have
is the animation playing idle so let's
test this let's actually click this key
auto play on load this will
automatically start playing idle and
we're going to want to Loop this and
then we're also going to
make the time 0.4 so it's going to go
from 0 0 to 0.4 and then Loop so let's
play and see what we have
all right we now have our animation
playing idle so
we can still move and everything and it
plays idle so it's working pretty nice
so now let's do that same thing for jump
or sorry not jump run let's do that for
run so let's make sure we select our
animated Sprite we go to jump or run and
then animation
and we're going to key the animation
I'm going to key the frame
I'm going to go to 0.1 make sure this
Frame next frame is selected again
next frame next frame
and again you have to do this manually
and essentially select each frame
manually alright from there we're going
to change this to 0.55
so we're going to go from 0 to 0.55 Loop
this and then for the jump what we're
going to do is actually we're going to
add another animation and call this fall
all right from the jump animation what
we'll do is we'll take the animated
Sprite we'll go from jump
to animation one more time we have to
key this and we have to key the first
frame and we'll go to fall
key the jump because that jump frame is
there we're going to go to frame one key
that and that's it so that's our fall
animation essentially
okay now that we have everything set up
we have idle frames all that we can now
access all the animations through
through code
right so the way we can do that is say
instead of atom here what we can do is
say on ready anim
actually we'll just remove this atom we
don't need the animated spray anymore so
instead what we can do is say
uh animation layer so we're going to
Auto load the animation player and not
the Animation Sprite the animation
player is accessing the Sprite so we no
longer need it so now what we can do we
want to do the exact same thing if in
direction we're going to say anim dot
play
run
and make sure that it's selected it's
written properly so we have run
so now we play idle by default and then
we can start running awesome okay now
that we've run we now want to do the
other animations again so it's the same
thing as animated Sprite but we're now
going to just add it all in so here this
is going to be idle and then again this
is going to be jump so let's copy paste
that and just put jump but now when we
play obviously we still have the same
problem as before so when I play
it doesn't show the jump et cetera Etc
and I don't change directions okay so
let's do the jump and all that stuff
first so let's think a little bit what
are we actually doing when we jump well
we're changing the velocity dot y right
when I move right and left I'm only
changing the x-axis right the the x
velocity but when I jump I'm changing
the y axis of the Velocity so now what
we can do is essentially check to see if
the velocity dot Y is zero or not if
it's zero that essentially means I'm not
in the air that also means I'm not I'm
on the floor right so what I can do is
say if velocity dot Y is equal to 0 then
we can run alternatively you can do not
equal zero something something else but
I'm just going to do is equal to zero so
now we'll do this for the idle and the
run so now
believe that should be it so now what we
should be able to do is check to see
what we have
there we go so now I can jump right
stop idle and jump okay now let's
actually look at the fall so in the fall
animation what we can do is do the same
idea however what's happening with the
velocity of Y is here we set it to
negative 400 all right so we basically
shoot it up and then what are we doing
we're adding gravity to it so we're
going to start adding to it that means
we're going to essentially make the
velocity
uh greater than zero right so here it's
going to be less than zero and here it's
going to be greater than zero so what we
can do is ask it if it's greater than
zero what we'll do is we'll play the
fall animation so now when I play
I jump
idle and fall right so now it's going to
see if I'm going down if I'm starting to
go down it's going to start playing the
fall animation right okay awesome next
up is I'm going to be looking at the
actual Sprite so how do we change the
direction well what we can do
is basically check for the direction so
let's actually take a look at this so
let's print the direction and see what I
get so sorry let's actually do this
outside of this function let's do it
right here so we're always printing it
so let's print this let's play so it's
printing zero if I start going to the
right it's going to print one if I go to
the left it's going to start printing
negative one right so what I can do is I
can do something with that right so I
can actually say let's say if Direction
whoops we just
we'll say Direction
is equal to one then what we can do or
actually we'll do negative one
we'll say oops
get
node animated Sprite lip
H equals to true so if you don't know
what this does if we go to our animated
Sprite
here we can now see a flip H function or
a property that basically allows me to
flip it
so let's go back to our script and add
that right so now we also have to flip
it back if our Direction isn't uh
negative one right so we're going to
have to say
false if it's not negative one however
this is also going to be true if it's
zero right so
if I play
it's always going to start facing to the
right now if that's something you want
you can totally do that or you can just
say l if
Direction equals one then we can just
flip it this way it'll just check for
these two conditions and then it'll just
leave it on the other
um thing so if I face the left it'll
face the left if I face the right it'll
leave it on the left right left
Etc right so now we have a nice moving
animation player okay let's just firstly
fix up the Collision so let's change
this up a little bit let's stop the game
let's go to our player and let's play
our Idol
by going here we play idle so let's
take our Collision shape and actually
try to make it match so let's turn off
the grid
what we can do if you have this issue is
we can lock the Animation Sprite so
let's do that and lock that and now
let's try to change the Collision shape
a little bit okay there we go so we now
have a nice Collision shape for our
player so now when I play
we now have a nice moving player on the
floor that jumps and runs and all that
stuff awesome we've now created our
player with animations and everything
all right so the next thing we're going
to be doing is creating a background so
go actually has a very nice built-in
system for this so the first thing we're
going to do is create a new node we're
going to create a Para
lags background here we go this one and
then we're going to add
error Lex layers okay so the layer
essentially is going to add pictures in
each layer and then it's going to kind
of go through that motion so let's
actually just do it and then I'll
explain it after so the first thing
we're going to want to do is look
through our Sprites and kind of find
what we want to use so the first thing
we're going to use is the back on the
very very back so we're going to use
this guy I'm going to set it up and just
put it in the back
we're going to save this as BG we'll
save it in the main scene we'll use this
as a parallax layer so now what we'll do
is we'll go there and now we'll
duplicate this and we'll take this guy
and we're gonna We're Not Gonna actually
we'll delete it
and then let's look at some other things
we can use let's use this one
so now we can kind of drag this in and
unfortunately there's only one of these
so what we'll do is we will just
duplicate this a few times so we get
like this
kind of move it up a little bit
try to make it fit nicely there we go
okay and now let's take those two
duplicate those move it
again
and move it
and that is it let's duplicate one more
time
all right there we go okay this is going
to be a bit awkward but it should work
okay so what we're going to do is we're
gonna use the motion we're gonna go to
motion and mirror so this is going to be
a bit awkward because the background
here Parallax layer is going to be at
one one of five two so we'll go to the
x-axis one one five two and now as you
can see it's been duplicated there now
however for the for the other one we're
going to want to duplicate it right
around there which will if we zoom in
it'll be
we can see 1232
so now we can see that it's been
duplicated one more time and it's all
the way on the right so now what we want
to do is go to our Parallax background
we'll rename this to BG
the entire thing please there we go and
we'll add a script and in here this is
actually very simple not much code we'll
take a variable we'll add that and then
we're just going to add a function
process
Delta and we'll say scroll offset.x
minus equals scrolling speed times Delta
so what this is going to do is basically
send our offset to the left so let's
play and see what we get
we have to actually add this let's add
it to our main scene so let's go to
background and let's add it here and
let's see what we get one more time
awesome we now have a moving background
and it should get duplicated infinitely
so let's wait a second to see how fast
how far it goes
okay hopefully you've kind of noticed
that it is infinite so it gets mirrored
every whatever pixel that we put right
so those were the mirrors that we put
and now let's close that that's actually
move this down a little bit let's take
all these and just move it down slightly
so it's on the bottom of the screen
awesome let's actually make sure we it's
pixelate it properly there we go
next up what we can do is we can change
the scale so the scale let's actually
unlink this and we'll scale this to one
uh we'll do 0.7 so what this is going to
do is basically make it go slower than
the background so now we have the front
going a bit slower than the back so now
we have a nice little Parallax
background where this front goes a
little slower than the back and lastly
what we can maybe do is look to add
something else we can maybe look to add
could add plants what is this
we could add this
but we're not going to we're just going
to delete that
but you guys got the idea you can kind
of add whatever you want to the
background we can maybe add a house here
let's duplicate
Parallax layer here
but on the bottom let's put this plant
house here delete the back
and then we'll put this one actually
behind the grass so we'll have it kind
of over here hiding in the back
and what we can do is just duplicate
this and kind of put a few in different
plate spots so that way we have a bit of
variety
awesome whoops
let's take these guys and just lock
those so I can't move them
and we'll take that and move it right
there
awesome
we now have a little bit of variety so
now we have
houses in the back and things in the
tree in the in the front so let's change
the houses one more time let's name this
houses
let's change the motion of this let's
make it we have to unlink this and let's
make it 0.5 and let's play one more time
and see what we get
awesome we now have a few houses that go
slightly slower than everything else in
fact if you don't want to you can just
make this zero and it won't move at all
so if you do that
they just won't move but it's up to you
you can do whatever you want and I
encourage you to be creative with The
Parallax background you know has a very
nice Parallax background and a way to do
this so let's close this let's go to our
world and let's add our background in
there too
in this one we're gonna actually make
something slightly different so what
we'll do is we'll put this to the top
and we're going to make it local
this is what this is going to do is
essentially add it to our scene and now
what we're going to do is delete the
houses we don't want those we're going
to delete this and that's it so now we
have our actual background of the uh
and everything in our actual scene so
now when I play this is what we get
instead so now what we can do is look to
actually add the ground so we'll let's
delete this ground
and now what we'll do is we'll just add
a
cold
we're going to add a grid map or a tile
set so we're going to search up Taos map
read this let's add it to the top what
we're going to do is we're going to go
to the top right we're going to see tile
set we're going to say new tile set the
tiles we'll take a look in a second but
what we'll do is we'll also have to find
the tiles that we're going to use so
let's use this one so in Sunnyland
phaser project we can find this tile set
there should be a few there's actually a
few duplicates so you're going to have
to kind of look for whatever you want
there's a lot of props as well that we
can look at there's layers which is cool
Sprites spreadsheets let's take a look
at the spreadsheet no we don't want that
okay so we're going to be using this
towel set okay so let's go in here we
can click the tile set and go here go to
the tile set on the bottom so we want to
edit the tile set not the tile map and
we're just going to drag this tile set
in and that's it so now what we can do
without doing any auto stuff we can
actually go to our tile map I'm going to
select the tile that we want and now
what we can do
is just draw
a faster way to do this is selecting the
rectangle now we can kind of zoom out
and just draw like this we can drag and
drop like that that's fine and then what
we can do is just fill in the dirt so go
here like that and now we have a dirt
ground which is actually what we want
let's make this a little prettier okay
and that'll be it for that so let's
play and see what happens well if you
might already realize what happens is
nothing we're going to go through the
floor so what we want to do is actually
add physics to the layers and the way we
can do that is by going to the tile map
we'll go to the right side we'll add
element to the physics let's go to the
Tau set what we're going to do now is
we're going to go to paint
we're going to Select Property we're
going to edit the physics layer and now
what we can do is add a physics layer to
each tile set itself or each tile so now
I click it that basically added a
collision shape to it and that is the
Collision shape you can edit it very
uniquely if you want but we're not going
to do that we're going to keep it as a
block so I'm just going to control Z and
leave it like that but if you do have
like a slanted slope you can do that by
just doing this right by having a slant
I don't believe we have any of that well
we do right there
um but we're probably not going to be
using that we have one there as well but
it's up to you we have one there as well
so that's cool we can maybe use that
later on okay so now let's see what we
get so let's play
and see what we got
awesome we now collide with the floor so
let's actually
um go over here let's delete the panel
and then let's fill in our dirt a little
bit because you can kind of see the
bottom
awesome and now what we can also do is I
believe we should be able to add walls
so let's actually add Collision to the
wall as well so let's go over to the
tile set and we're still in the pane so
let's just add a collision here let's
add it to all of them
we can pretty much add it to all of
these and let's go back to our tile map
and now we can add a wall on the side so
if we go to Terrain
oh sorry we have to go to map
open up our map and
let's draw so let's actually what we can
do is create a long ground
much more dirt under it
and then what we can do
is actually out of the wall so let's add
a wall that basically shows that we're
moving we can't go any further
let's add some dirt
there we go and let's do the same on the
other side we can do over here we'll do
like one little wall here and we
shouldn't have to add anything after
that because I'll show you guys how to
actually make sure we our screen doesn't
go off so here you can see that I can
see from the left now if I want to limit
my camera this is actually very easy
what I can do is go into my player into
my camera and there's a limit section
now the Left Right top is is basically
this part so the left is this guy and
the left I want to set it to zero the
top I want to set it to zero as well so
this will basically limit it to those
two points so now in my world when I
play
it'll limit it to the to the right of
that corner if you want to limit to the
bottom as well you can totally do that
you can limit it like under here if you
don't want to see the dirt or if you
don't want to draw that dirt that's
totally fine all right now that we have
that let's take a look at some monsters
that we can make so let's create a new
node we're going to make a kinematic
body which is not kinematic character
body they change the name let's add a
collision shape to it so we don't get
that error and then let's give it a
shape we'll give it a little capsule
let's zoom in and let's add a animated
Sprite
so this one is going to be a lot simpler
than the actual player so it's going to
be a lot easier so we can just do an
animated Sprite and no animation
hopefully we'll go through it together
and see what we end up with so let's
close all these and look for our
frog you guys that we want so here we
have frog jump and frog Idol so let's go
to the animated Sprite let's go in here
let's have whoop
let's erase all this say idle and then
let's add
no
let's see what else we have
and this little awesome guy
it's kind of walking
you have a little enemy death that's
awesome we can probably use that
okay let's add the jump in here
oh we can't do that we have to actually
now we can use the animated spray so
let's go here to the add frames let's
find this guy so let me actually
look up here
so Sunny Sand
files
it'll be in here PNG
spreadsheet and frog jump
now if I zoom in it should just be three
and one and I can just select all of
them
and let's go to idle let's go here and
add the idle this one will be four and
one we can just do that and select all
of them
and now we can kind of move this guy up
a little bit let's turn off the grid
snap or grid and let's move it into the
middle like that just save this as frog
put in the main world let's save and now
what we can do is also add
yeah let's add the death animation for
now as well so let's add death
let's load the death animation so here
we have one two three four five six six
horizontal
and one vertical let's select all of
them
there we go and now what we can do is go
to our frog rename it frog and save it
as frog and we're not going to have a
We're not gonna have a template this
time instead we're going to select the
default what this is going to do is just
create this we'll remove all this let's
go to 2D let's go to our capsule in fact
actually let's change this to a square
because there's something else I want to
do later on let's add it like this
just like that
and now what we can do is we're going to
add a area 2D now what an area 2D is is
essentially an area for detection as
well as physics and audio info influence
so what we can do here is we can add a
collision shape to it
and we can add a circle and this will
essentially act as our player detection
detection
and now what we can do is add a node
where we basically say if a body entered
we'll connect it will do something so
now we can also say if body dot name is
equal to player then we'll do something
then we'll say run
player
because what this is going to do is
we're going to ask there's a lot of
bodies that generally will enter this
area right so if there's another frog
that enters the area that will count as
a body so we don't want to chase a
another frog we want to chase the player
so the way we can do that is by checking
the name of it so if we can say dot name
is player right make sure it's always
case capital or case sensitive so we can
paste it just in case then we'll print
player for now so let's go to our scene
let's go to our world and actually add
our frog so let's go over here add our
frog and let's play
and he's not moving obviously but let's
see what happens I got to stop printing
that thing let's start printing the
direction so we actually see what's
happening
let's try one more time
but now every time I enter him it says
player and obviously as you can see
we're on top of him so let's actually
add some gravity to him so
we can see here this is how we add
gravity so let's actually do that let's
go over here let's add a physics
process function and add gravity so
let's add a comment to let's say this uh
gravity or frog
and we have to actually set the gravity
so let's also do that let's bring this
guy into the
frog so now we can add gravity to the
Frog so now what we can do and check is
take a look at our project
and our frog will not fall why is that
let's take a look velocity plus equals
gravity okay so here I just realized we
have to add move and slide for it to
actually fall so let's go to play and
now our frog actually falls to the
ground so because now he actually has
gravity all right so the next thing
we're going to want to do is actually do
something when the player enters so what
we can do is essentially look for the
player so the first thing we want to do
is go to our 2D and organize this a
little bit so let's add a node
activity and this will be for the player
let's add this in so we can actually
name that player and then let's add
another node
let's add a node 2D and say
moms
and we'll basically add frogs to this
mobs and now what we can do is go from
the script and we'll drag in our player
and this is the path to our player so
what we can do here is say let's say
variable player outside
and then inside of here we'll say player
equals this so that that is the path to
the player now what we can do or look to
do is say player Dot
dot position
or Global position
all right let's print this and see what
we get
so let's print
Global position so now we're going to be
able to actually find our player by
getting his Global position and we have
to actually convert it to a string
because
this is a vector so let's play One More
Time
or not
Global position dice felt wrong
okay so this is actually getting a
string so we need to actually make sure
we get the node that's why
okay so we don't actually have to
convert it to a string I don't believe
so let's try this
Play Enter and it'll print our position
so what we want to do is actually find
the direction in which player the player
is in in
a response to where the player is or
where the mob is right the way we can do
that is
basically saying variable Direction
equals
we're going to take the player Direction
player dot position
minus self dot position right so you
don't actually have to say let me make
sure to hit that in right position
you don't actually have to say self but
it's nice kind of see that self Dot and
then we're going to normalize this by
saying Dot normalized and now what we
can do is say if Direction
is greater than zero
we're going to actually only look at the
dot X Direction so we'll say dot X is
greater than zero what we'll do is
we'll actually see which direction it's
in so if it's greater than zero that
should mean we're on the right now if
we're on the other side we'll say else
you say let's print this and say left
so now we can do is print this or play
and see what we get so when I do this
I'm on the right but if I enter from
here I'm on the left awesome so now what
we want to do is we want to actually be
doing most of this on the other side
right so
what we can do is basically take all
this and add it to the physics process
however this might not work perfectly
because what we want to do is actually
all right let's make sure we're not
indented improperly here there we go
what we want to be doing is basically
chasing only if the player is here so we
can do is add another variable and call
it Chase and we'll default it to be
false right so now if we enter what we
can do is say Chase equals true now we
want to be able to do is say if Chase is
false then we'll stop chasing right so
now we can say is Go to the
area 2D we'll go to the node and we'll
say body exit and we'll copy paste all
this and just say false
if it's if the player left the area
right and make sure it's indented
properly otherwise we'll get an error
awesome and now we'll be what's going to
be happening is it's only it's always
going to be getting the direction of the
player but it'll only Chase if Chase is
true right so now we can do is say
in here we'll say if Chase is true then
we'll actually Chase so
let's print
Chase
right
okay and to do that what we can do
is actually very simple we'll just
change the velocity of the actual rock
so to do that we're going to just say
velocity dot x equals Direction dot x
times speed so we have to actually make
sure we set the speed so let's go over
here and set the speed to 50.
awesome so now that we have the
direction and the speed we can do that
and what we can do
is we can actually just do this outside
of the direction however the direction
is useful because what's going to be
happening is we're going to want to flip
the actual character right so what we
can do is say in here
let's actually add this
right here let's do this
let's add all that and then we'll say if
Chase is true then we'll do all this and
then if the direction is on the right
what we can do is we're not going to
change the velocity we're going to say
get node
animated Sprite
dot blip
H equals false right because on the
right side
oh no sorry we want it to be true
because he's facing the left by default
so true and then on the other one if
he's facing the left then we'll make it
false so here we'll make it
false just like that
okay great so now let's play and see
what we got
so now you can see he's chasing us
whenever we enter so
hopefully if I exit it should stop or
not okay let's take a look at what's
going on
okay I see we got to actually reset the
velocity so if it if Chase is not true
what we'll do is we'll say velocity dot
X is equal to zero so let's play and
let's try one more time
and now when I go in his area he's going
to chase me when I leave he's gonna stop
because the velocity is now zero okay
next up we are going to basically
animate him so what's happening here if
Chase is true then we'll uh yeah node
and play the animation so we'll say get
node animated Sprite dot play
um which did I name it we got to make
sure I type it right jump
we'll say play jump and then
it's not true then what we can do is
play
let's play
let's play and see what's going on
all right so by default he's playing the
little frog thing so we can do is kind
of slow that down
make it look a little better so let's go
into our idle
and what we can do is copy this by
saying Ctrl C and then copy paste it a
few times after
so now what it'll look like
a little better it'll kind of do that a
little frog thing and then pause for a
sec
now what we can do is enter it'll start
jumping and running towards us
every a little bit because it's kind of
small
all right let's take a look at what
we've got
all right I think we got our restarted
in order for it to take effect there we
go so now it's chasing us and when I
flip it'll start chasing us towards the
other side awesome so now what we can do
is we're going to add another player
detection or another area so let's make
this invisible we're going to add
another Collision shape basically so
we're going to duplicate this and we're
going to say
player death
we're gonna go to I'm gonna make this
visible we're going to actually create a
new thing so let's actually just reset
this and create a rectangle so let's put
this on the top now this is very
important that we actually make this
Collision proper and we want to put it
on the top of the Frog
right here
like that and now we can do is we can we
have to disconnect these
and reconnect them because we've changed
the name so it's going to chase make it
a new one and then what we'll say is
we'll check to see
if
body dot name is equal layer
then what we can do is basically just Q3
now what Q3 will do is just delete the
player so or delete the Frog itself so
now what's going to happen is we're
going to jump on top of the Frog
hopefully I can do it
there we go and then he dies so what we
can do instead is play the animation
death so let's do that by saying
get node animated Sprite and play death
now you might notice this might not be
perfect because something's going to
happen it's going to delete right away
it's not going to work
let's try one more time there we go it
didn't play the animation but it did
what happened is it did however it's
queuing free right away so what we can
do is say await
um
animated we have to get the node
get node
animated Sprite
and then what a weight does is it's
essentially going to wait for something
to happen it's going to wait for a
signal so the signal we're waiting for
is if we go to player death we can go to
sorry animated Sprite we can see that
there's a bunch of signals here we're
gonna look for the animation finished
we can type in animation finished and we
don't have to type it in like this we
just have to
have like that and now it'll wait for it
to finish and then it'll keep free so
now if we go to the depth okay it's five
FPS that's fine let's play and see what
we got
so let's hop and chase us
hopefully it works or not
okay so what was happening what the
reason why I saw playing death is
because we are always going to be
overriding it with this so what we want
to do is we want to go over here and say
if
get node we'll say if get node dot what
was it I think it was animation is
equals yeah
then we're gonna do this we're gonna say
not equals Death
and that should hopefully work so now
we're going to also add this to the jump
one so let's add it here
make sure I don't have any errors
okay so we just have to restart the game
and it'll work so now we can see that
it's playing and then it'll play idle
and then when I jump on top of it it's
gonna play depth but it's gonna
constantly play so what we can do to fix
that is actually very simple we go over
here and turn off the loop in the depth
so it'll finish and then it'll shoot
free so let's try one more time
okay we gotta make sure that we have the
idle selected we'll fix that in a second
I'll show you how to fix that so play
we'll jump on top of him he'll play the
death animation and disappear okay so
the first thing we want to do is let's
make sure that we're always playing the
idle at ready so let's say function
um ready
we'll say get node animated thingy
majiggy and play
idle so now that'll always default to
the idle animation by uh when we are in
the ready so here another thing we want
to start doing is two things let's start
let's first make sure that he's staying
still and then let's also say Chase
equals false I actually don't think we
need to make the velocity equal zero we
can just remove that and say this
and now when he's chasing us and then
when I jump on top of him he'll just
explode and die all right let's make the
explosion slightly faster so let's go
here
image Sprite and we'll go to death
and say 10.
oh we'll do is like let's do eight I
think eight is good and now let's also
add something so that when the player
hits him he also explodes but does
damage to the player so to do that what
we're going to want to do is add Health
to the player so let's add Health
there we go and we'll say equals 10.
now we want to actually be able to see
that so let's add a UI for this so let's
add a canvas layer
and this canvas layer is going to act as
our UI so let's add UI and rename it as
UI
didn't mean to do that let's add a label
to print out our HP and this let's
rename it to HP
we're going to add a script it's going
to be built in because this is very
simple let's go to the process function
and what we'll say is
text equals get node
we want to get the player
DOT health
let's make sure we type this all out
properly we get the node we're going to
say this and then we're going to kind of
convert it to a string and then let's
also add a text that says
whoops
uh HP we'll say HP for now
and then add a space and then maybe
something call in there so that way we
have HP and then the player's Health
okay so now in our 2D scene let's move
this guy a little bit to the left and
then let's go to theme override we're
going to go to font no not font uh size
here we go font size and let's create
increase it a bit so let's say HP so we
can see HP right there let's increase
the size just slightly so we can see it
and then we're also going to change the
color to font so we're just going to
make that true and let's play and let's
see what we get
we now have our HP on the top now what
we want to do is basically add a go to
the Frog and now what we're going to do
is we're going to duplicate the player
Def and we're going to say player
Collision
now this guy is going to actually be
very simple we're going to
flip him
let's actually
go to the animated Sprite let's play the
idle so we can see the Frog let's go to
the Collision let's make it unique
and what we're going to do is we're
going to make it slightly bigger than
the
Collision shape of the actual frog so we
want to do it like that but not too big
because this if the player touches this
they're going to explode and damage the
player so let's do this
and let's actually add a collision let's
add the
thing to it so the signal so let's
disconnect it and then reconnect it
because we've changed the name and then
again we have to check if it's the
player and this one is actually very
simple because all we can do or have to
do is just do the exact same thing here
so let's copy paste this
and then we'll just say body DOT health
minus equals let's say three so it'll
damage the player by three in fact what
we can actually do is take all this and
let's actually create a separate
function and say function def
and let's add it in there
and then I can just call death from here
and then I can also call death from here
instead so now we've shortened our code
quite a bit
okay let's play and see what we got
let's play if I jump on top of him I
don't take damage but now if I play
again
run into him I take damage so you saw
that HP went down by three awesome we
now have a really well platform it's
pretty cool we can now jump around and
run away and if I jump on top of him or
hate him I hate take damage so if you
want you can increase the area as much
as you want so you can kind of increase
it like this if you'd like kind of
increase it above
just like that
it's up to you so we can do that
whatever you want so I would encourage
you to play around with the collisions
so it's very important that we actually
have that the proper collisions so one
more thing we're going to want to do is
in our player let's actually go to the
process function and we'll add a new
thing where we're going to say if health
is smaller than zero or we'll say
smaller than or equal to then we're just
going to queue free because you know we
don't want our player to exist even
though our health is low right and then
we can do is go back to the main menu so
we can say
tree
dot change scene to file and go back to
the main scene so in here
nope that's it let's add a few more
frogs so we can duplicate this a few
times and kind of just drop them
wherever you want
make sure they're in the world
there we go and now when we play
and I hit them all and I die I go back
to the main scene all right now that
we've pretty much got the base of the
game next up we're going to be working
with a few new Concepts in gudo so let's
just make a new folder and call it
Global and this is basically just going
to hold any Global folders or things
that we have so it's not just going to
be a global variable but Global scripts
so we're going to make one script called
game
I'm going to go over here I'm going to
duplicate this and call it utils for
utility all right in the game folder
we're going to go over here we're going
to delete all this and just call it or
we're going to write variable let's see
what do we want as a global variable
let's say player HP equals 10.
no not Q10 just 10. and then variable
player
MP
equal to five
or actually we'll say player or just
gold equals 10 or 0. this gold should
start at zero not key zero silly kiddo
all right next up is we're gonna have to
actually make this Global so how do we
do that well in Godot there's actually a
very easy way to do that which is
actually just to autoload it in the
project settings so head over to the
product settings in not in general we're
going to go to the top as you can see
right here in autoload we're gonna click
this path over here we're going to go to
Global and find our script we're going
to open it and we're going to add it
make sure you don't forget to add it
next up we're going to do the same thing
for utils so we're going to add that and
add it and now we have both of these
Auto loaded and now they are enabled so
let's hover over to the utils and delete
this as well so let's take a look at
what actually happened in Godot so when
I play here's our game but we can see in
our remote section on the top left we
have root and we have game utils and
main main is our actual game right
that's what we're playing on that's the
background the play quit button Etc and
these are the two uh
the files that we just loaded these are
the two scripts that we've just loaded
they're technically scenes but they're
also a script right
it's technically it's actually a script
though so that way we can now access
these things globally from anywhere and
I'll show you how to do that in just one
second so next up is the saving and
loading so we're going to go through
some file access in Godot so good has a
built-in file access uh functionality
and it's very very good and it's very
simple so we're going to go through this
together and work through this easily so
the first thing we'll have to do is
we're going to create two variables
called uh save path
and we're just going to say we're going
to give it a string empty string for now
we're just going to have this save path
so for the save path what we're going to
be doing or using is going to be res at
savegame.bin so what this is going to be
doing is if you look at res we can see
that here this is also called rest so
this is basically going to save it in
that folder now usually if you're
actually releasing this game you should
do users this is global it works on
Windows and I believe Android and I
believe
um iOS so for the sake of this video
we're going to be doing res but you can
you should and can use users instead all
right next up is we're going to create
two functions one is going to be the
save
game function
let's pass for now
and then let's make another function
called load game
all right and let's pass in here so we
don't get an error okay the first thing
we want to do in our save game is we're
going to have to create a file so to do
that we're going to say fair variable
file equals file access dot open
save path and then we're going to write
so this is essentially going to be able
to allow us to create a file and this is
going to be a temporary file in the
actual function this is the actual file
this is this is actually where we make
the file all right but this is going to
allow us to create a temporary file to
actually write inside inside of it to
actually save right because here we're
trying to save so we should be writing
right so if you actually think about
this in load we do the same thing but
we're just going to read instead we're
not going to write it we're going to
read so it's going to be the exact same
thing but we're just going to read
instead of writing it so next up there's
a few different ways and things to do to
actually save the way the way I like to
do it is to save it kind of as a Json
file and the best way to have a Json
file is to have a dictionary and so to
make a dictionary is actually quite easy
we can just say
variable data it's going to be we're
going to have a semicolon here and this
is going to allow us to specify what it
is so this is going to be sorry not data
just dictionary and I'm going to say
equals and brackets and that's going to
allow us to actually State our
dictionary you don't have to actually
have this I believe you can just remove
this and just have it like that and
it'll say it's a dictionary or Godot
will assume it's a dictionary but this
allows to actually say that 100 for
certainty this is a dictionary okay so
the next thing we're going to want to do
is make the keys and the actual value of
those keys so the first thing we want to
do is we want to save our
player player HP and to do that we can
access it by saying game dot player HP
and the key we're going to save it as is
the exact same thing so we're going to
say player HP as player HP so that's
usually how I make the keys so sorry
we're gonna have a semicolon here not a
comma and then to write another one
we're just going to have a comma there
and then instead of player HP we're
going to say gold as the key
we're going to also save it as gold
there we go so now we can save two
values inside of a dictionary this is a
super simple and fast way to save a file
instead of saving everything manually or
saving one at a time this is just going
to allow us to save everything inside of
a dictionary and then now we're just
going to store it inside of a Json so
first we have to actually convert it to
Json so to do that again we have
built-in functions to do that nicely um
godot4 has updated so now we can just
say Json string is going to be equal to
Json dot stringify data so this is going
to just basically take our data our
dictionary and stringify it right and
now this is this is the easy part
we're just going to store it we're going
to say file dot store line and that's it
so now we this should actually work so
now what we can do is let's go to our
main let's go to our function here let's
add a function say ready
and then we're going to say utils
dot save game I just copy pasted it so
now when I play it it's going to save
the game and hopefully it doesn't error
awesome no errors and now what we can do
is we can actually
open this up
and we can see that we have savegame dot
bin and if we open this
if I can bring it over there we go
there's our notepad so you can open a
notepad and you can see here's our
values here's our Json data string that
we made so we have gold and player HP so
now we can close this we don't need it
and minimize that and that is how we
save now how do we load well it's
actually very similar so all we have to
do
is check if the file exists so if file
access file is this save path equals
true or we can just say
there I like to I always like to specify
if it's equal equals to true not just
have it there but it's up to you that's
more of a coder's preference
then what we'll add is say
if we have not reached the end of file
so this means end of file reached
we have not reached that then we're
going to start loading so this is where
we actually load
so first thing we have to do is actually
create a like stringify so we have to
actually read the file to do that we say
variable current line equals Json parse
string from file.getline so this is
going to allow us to essentially parse
the string and actually read what's
inside of that Json file so next part is
we just load it and to do that all we
have to do is say if current line we can
actually just say game.player class is
equal to current line at this right so
the current line will essentially take
all the values that we have inside of
the file and convert it into a Godot
readable thing so Godot will actually be
able to read it and then Godot will just
load it in by accessing it through the
array right so this is the key to that
dictionary sorry it's not an array it's
a dictionary and that'll that's the key
to that dictionary right and so it this
is going to access this guy right so the
saved value that we have so let's try
this out so
one note is Godot three you used to have
to close it so I think you used to have
say file close
oh it's still there but we don't have to
do that anymore though which is actually
really nice
because if you would forget to do that
then a bunch of things would happen so
here let's try saving it so let's save
and then load load game so now that
we've loaded it we have we will now save
and load this is basically the way to
what did we do here player class we have
to load the player HP right and I'll
save the gold make sure it's capitalized
all right let's try one more time okay
so this is a fast way when I save and
load this is a fast way to basically
overwrite our all our data and reset it
to zero essentially so now what we can
do is we can comment that out and now
let's go to our frog and in our deaths
what we can do is say game Dot gold plus
equals one all right let's do five okay
not key five oh my God
E5
and then we'll say utils dot save game
so every time we kill a frog we'll get
five gold and we'll also save the game
so let's actually print our gold so
let's go over here to our UI let's
duplicate this
rename this to gold
and a quick way to make sure that we
don't blunder this up is we have to make
sure that the script is unique so this
script and this script are the same so
they've taken the same script so we have
to make sure that we go to one of them
any one of them and make it unique we
can do that by going to the bottom right
and just saying make unique and now when
I click it I'm David it'll now save it
as its own unique file right so these
are built-in Scripts so it's not gonna
We're not gonna be able to find it but
they are here and there they are on the
left and now what we can do is change
this up to Gold so we can change this to
gold and then instead of printing The
Helpful plant gold
and we have to actually make sure to say
that this is from the global function
goals
and now what we can also do is actually
change this to be a global function and
say
game.health and we can also say oh no we
can just leave that
but we have to make sure that this is
player HP we'll also have to replace it
in our player and frog so here
where do we do damage we do damage
here we go body.health instead of
body.health minus equals three what
we'll do is we'll say game dot player
Health minus equals three all right
lastly we have to go back to our player
and make sure that the health is
actually going to look at the
game.player house and now we should be
able to just delete this health we don't
need it
all right we'll just make a few lines
there all right there we go so now what
we can do is just play and test it out
so let's play Let's go to play oh
we have to move our gold otherwise we're
not going to be able to see it so let's
go back to our world and actually move
our gold down and this should update
automatically so if I go back to my
player there we go there's our gold and
now when I kill something it gives me
five gold and now if I close it I don't
have to save or anything because every
time I've killed a frog it saves already
so now let's play and see what we get
there's our 15 gold we've already gotten
15 gold because every time we killed it
it saved that gold so let's take a look
at our folder let's take a look in our
file so here we can open this up and we
can see that the gold has changed it is
now 30 and our player HP is also 70
right or seven sorry because we've
reduced it by three and we got hit
awesome so our files now work that is
great
all right the next thing we're going to
do is Collectibles so so far we have
frogs and let's take these frogs and
just let's drag all of them and just
move them to the right a little bit
let's actually move them a little
further and then here we're going to
have some Collectibles so let's do that
let's um close this and let's add a new
scene let's close the player and frog we
don't need that anymore and let's go to
other node and we're going to create an
area 2D this is going to be the perfect
thing for collectible because this is
essentially just going to check for a
player right so let's add another
Collision or another node and a
collision shape and let's give it a
shape a circle and here I think an
animated Sprite is probably perfect and
I will explain why in a second so here
um I think we all we have is cherries I
think that's the only thing we have
yeah that's how all we have so let's go
to animated Sprite let's create an
animation for it
actually go into the animation we'll
just say idle
and let's just drag all these frames in
and there we go we now have our Cherry
let's actually play it so we can do that
by doing that and now what we can do is
make sure we just actually we can just
keep in the middle like that that's fine
and then let's actually try to give it
the proper shape so let's actually lock
this take the Collision shape and kind
of give it a nice shape here all right
let's save this as cherry
let's create a new folder
let's we'll say collect doubles
save it let's go to area 2D name it
cherry
we'll add a script
we'll go to
node we'll create it and now what we can
do is save this and then
we're going to delete all this we're
going to go to Cherry and go to node
I'm going to say and body entered and
this is really easy because we can just
say if body dot name is equal to player
then we can Q3
and I would I hope you assume you know
what we're going to do we're just going
to add to our gold if you want to make a
Cherry like stat you can do that but I'm
just going to add to our goals so let's
add five and now let's go to our world
scene
and let's close all this let's go to our
collectible here it is and drag that in
let's create a new node so or a new
container for that so this is going to
be our collectibles
all right let's add that in and there's
going to be a very good reason why I'm
going to be doing Collectibles is
because so let's play
when we play
what is happening I do I know what's
happening what's happening is our
players HP is below zero and so when I
go to that scene it's uh going back to
the main menu okay so here's our Cherry
when I collect it it cue freeze Okay so
that's cool but how do I make it a
little nicer a little smoother so it
kind of feels more like a game well
Godot has this really nice thing called
tween so what we can do is we'll tweet
it so instead of just queuing free right
away what we can do is we're going to
say get actually we'll say variable
between equals get tree
dot create so here we have timer and
tween we'll do timer in a second but for
now let's do tween and then what we can
do is say tween Dot
tween property
between property there it is we're going
to Tween the property so what this is as
you can see we can see a few
um things that we can add so object
property the node path final value and
then duration you can't really see it
but that's what it says duration so the
object is Which object do we want to
tweet well we want to Tween the Cherry
right so self right or we can actually
say get node whatever and then drag this
in but we could just say self in this
case all right and then the property
node path so the property is well the
property right so the position in this
case right so we want to between the
position so position and then what is
the final position that we want it to be
in well we can say position minus
Vector two
zero one fifteen so what does this mean
basically the final value is gonna we're
gonna take the original value subtract
150 to the y-axis why why are we
subtracting and not adding well because
if you can actually look here so if we
zoom in a little bit it's hard to see
but if you
kind of pay attention on the left hand
side you can see negative 5 negative 10
and it goes upwards in negatives right
on the x-axis you can see that it's
negative on the x-axis here just
normally and then goes positive in the Y
and the x-axis on this side right now in
the y-axis it's reversed right so Godot
actually does this and so we need to
make sure we subtract and not add okay
and then the duration will be like I
don't know one second and then this is
the perfect part instead of saying Q3
right away or waiting or ask creating a
timer what we can do is we can say
between Dot
um tweet callback and then from here we
can actually say something so callback
the callable is is a function or like
something that I want to do right so in
this case I can just say Q free now it
in this case we don't actually call the
function we just call or call it
function with brackets we just say Q3
like that and we can delete that and now
when we play
and now it goes up it takes about a
second it goes up 150 that's a little
too much so why don't we do like 50.
let's play around with this number let's
play
it goes up about 50. that's a lit that's
not bad but let's try one more time
let's do
let's do a point three and then for this
we'll do like 25
all right let's play one more time let's
see what that looks like
okay awesome that's not bad and we've
kind of started something but now what
there's something else I could do well I
could interpolate the property of
something else and if you're thinking
you could make it invisible so this is
actually a very good trick is to do
things at once we're going to Tween two
things essentially we're going to Tween
the position to make it go up and then
we're also going to Twee in the
visibility so if you go to visibility we
can see modulate is a thing so we can
modulate this to become invisible slowly
like that so it looks like it's
disappearing right so to do that
we basically copy paste this when it say
self instead of position we're going to
say modulate modulate we have to make
sure we spell this right and we're going
to do the a so we're going to say
modulate
to zero so we can just take all this and
say zero because we're going to take our
modulate a so modulate this guy the a
value and we're going to take it from
225 55 sorry and we're going to go all
the way to zero now the duration we
might want to do
I will do a 0.3 let's see what we get
so let's play
and see what we get
all right so there you go so now it kind
of looks like it becomes invisible as we
collect it why don't we create let's
play around with these a little bit so
let's do like 35
we'll do 0.2
and 0.35 for that
and play
all right there we go now something you
may notice is is hard to notice but it
doesn't start becoming invisible
essentially until this is done so this
goes and then this goes so the total
time is about 0.5 so what we have to do
is essentially create another tween we
have to say tween one and then make this
here and then let's play One More Time
yeah we're going to want to Tween after
that so let's play one more time sorry
and let's see there we go so now it
actually looks a little better so it
looks like we're actually becoming
invisible over time now you can play
around with these numbers I will right
now you're gonna see me playing around
with them and there you go that's a
pretty nice tween collected okay
the last thing I want to teach is timers
so let's take a look at
timer so let's go to Collectibles let's
create this
let's delete all this now what we'll do
is there's two options we can either add
a timer node right so here or we can
actually create a node or a tween a
timer so we can say here get tree no we
can't say get tree we can say create
timer but not outside of here it has to
be inside of a ready function but we're
not actually going to do this we're just
going to use the node instead
so what we're going to do is we're going
to actually delete this cherry and the
reason being is because what we're going
to do is we're going to spawn in
children so we're going to be learning
two things timer and spawning in the
children so from here what we're going
to do is we're going to say variable
Cherry equals
load no preload
and then we have to find the chair yeah
look at that it's right there so you
have to find the path of the Cherry so
if you don't know where it is it doesn't
if it didn't pop up for you right away
that's okay what you can do is go to the
cherry on the left you can either drag
it in right so you can take it drag it
in and it'll give you the path or what
you can do is go right click
and there should be a copy path or Ctrl
shift C all right and then you can see
here if I go over here and try to copy
paste over it it'll work fine but then
you have to make sure it's it's as a
string
okay next up is a ready function let's
actually nope not a ready function what
we're going to do is we're going to now
connect a signal from the timer so if we
go to the timer and go to the signals we
can see the timeout time
out function we're going to connect that
to the Collectibles so let's go here
and what we're going to do
I just realized I spelled Cherry wrong
we're in here what we're going to do is
we're going to say variable
Cherry I keep saying Cherry with an a I
don't know why Cherry temp and then
we're going to say cherry dot
instantiate this is essentially going to
allow us to actually create it so we're
going to create this thing we're going
to have it in our hand now to actually
do something with it so we've
essentially taken this chair and put it
in our hand now we want to actually add
it into the scene right so to do that
all we have to do is say add child and
then we're going to add the Cherry temp
and that's it so let's play and see what
we got well we're not going to get
anything because we have to actually
start the timer so
if you go over here to the right we can
see auto start and we have to turn that
on so let's do that
let's play
and nothing happens obviously so let's
go to remote and see what's happening so
we can see here we have a bunch of
cherries they're being created but
what's happening we need to actually
right so if you actually added them it
it's hard to see but maybe I can play
around with this
you can see them at the top left it's
very hard to see but they're at the top
left what's happening is that all these
cherries that we've created are at
position zero so what we can do before
we add it we can say
cherry.temp.position
equals Vector two and from this we have
to actually kind of
look at the position so we'll say 296.
so we'll say 296 and then the position
will say 100. okay let's play and see
what we get
play
and now we can see the cherries are up
there let's actually lower it a little
bit because it's really high up
we want to say
hmm
I'm not sure why it's not doing that
that's uh
let's do this as 400 let's try one more
time
let's see where they're being created
oh that's why this is the x-axis not the
y-axis I mix them up my apologies all
right let's try one more time
there we go and now it'll be created on
the floor but there's a problem as you
can see they're always being spawned in
that one position so let's create it on
the ground but randomize it throughout
the ground right so to do that
we can go over here we can say variable
RNG dot or equals random number
generator dot new now what is this we
can say one more thing we'll say is
random Rand int
equals round
dot f I believe it's RNG yeah RNG dot
random I
and then the random eye let's take a
look at what this does now if you ever
wonder what something does if you kind
of see a function like this and you
don't know what it does we can do this
is a very great tip if you hit control
hold control and then hover the thing
the function and click it it'll take you
to what it is okay so Random I returns a
blah blah blah between zero and
something something that's not exactly
what we want in fact if we look right
below that we'll see something a little
better Randy range this will allow us to
go from something to something so this
actually works a little better for what
we want we don't want a completely
random number all the way to this number
because that's a really large number
that I'm not even going to try to say so
let's go back here and instead of Randy
we're going to say Randy range awesome
now what range do we want this from
let's say 10 to 400. so this will
essentially give us a random range
between 10 to 400 and then place it
anywhere from 10 to 400 on the x-axis
let's go back to our script and actually
use this as the
x-axis I will almost put in the y-axis
again silly me all right let's play
and now we can see it's somewhat more
randomized
there we go so now it's actually more
random and it's being spawned in
properly and one other thing you can do
is change the timer you can change it to
like three seconds four seconds whatever
you want and that's it that's the timer
and we've learned how to use a timer and
we use how to add children so this is
actually a very good tool to use we can
always add children one other tip you
can do so let's say let's actually
this is completely for educational
purposes this isn't actually going to
solve anything but let's create a note
here and let's say I want to spawn All
My Children here instead right let's say
let's say you're spawning mobs instead
of
um a cherry right
what I can do is I can say get node
and then I can add those children to
that node instead so I can do this
so get node node 2D add children share
time okay so it'll add all the children
in here instead of collectible right so
when I play Let's go to remote let's
actually play and see what's happening
let's go back to world let's go back to
Collectibles Cherry Cherry oh there we
go so now we can see all our Shares are
being added to the node 2D awesome
that's it for the cherries okay and
that's the end of the course I hope you
guys really enjoyed this course it was a
lot of fun doing it together with you
guys and if you guys would like to see
more content like this definitely check
out my channel it'll be in the link down
below and if you guys want I have a
Discord that you can definitely check
out and join if you need any help with
this course I will always be around to
try and help I have a bunch of other
series as well on my channel so
definitely go check those out such as an
RPG series a a farming Series where we
kind of go through how to kind of
recreate uh some different variety of
farming games and I believe I also have
one that's kind of like an action uh
survivor.io game and so that one's kind
of interesting and recently or soon I
will be releasing a 3D RPG series that
will be a lot of fun so definitely go
subscribe to my channel and check that
out and if you guys like Godot
definitely use it for all your future
projects it's a lot of fun and it's
really simple and Godot is always
growing and it's really cool to see that
so definitely check that out and I will
see you guys around hopefully bye-bye